I am joined today by Luke Vargas who has
joined us from all over the world from
recent years today in Seoul South Korea
he is United Nations bureau chief for
talk media news he has been traveling
with our fearless leader President
Donald J Trump it is very very late
where Luke is and we are going to talk
about the trip so far the trip started
of course after a brief stop at Trump's
hotel in Waikiki in Japan where Donald
Trump met with Shinzo Abe a as well as
the Japanese Emperor how is that
relationship working Luke between Shinzo
Abe a and trumpet it on camera
it seems very strained but I don't know
what it's like actually in person no
it's quite normal in person and I don't
think this is I think it's a real
relationship I mean it's a it's a
friendship that a bei pursued right at
the outset right after Trump was elected
even before he was the president Bobby
made a visit to Trump Tower visited the
president-elect the first world leader
to really welcome him so
enthusiastically a lot of this was born
of necessity Japan needs allies so he
took a risk he'd be friended Trump you
know and he laid it on thick
in that visit to Japan I mean the first
meal you know I personally kind of
recoiled thinking I've wanted to go to
Japan and eat all their food for years
and the first meal that Trump eats when
he goes there is a hamburger then I play
golf they played golf with up one of the
world's top pros and we've seen some
footage of Trump actually playing that
day he his swing looked a horrible and
yet in the press conference after a BAE
says it was neck-and-neck the whole way
I mean he is just flattering Trump to
the umpteenth degree but the payoff
seems real also I mean Trump is one of
the big messages of this trip is he's
going to each of these countries and
complaining about the imbalance in trade
he's actually formalizing those
complaints when it comes to China taking
them to the World Trade Organization
asking the US Trade Representative to
investigate Chinese practices that are
unfair he's not doing the same to Japan
though and it makes one think there
might be some sort of gentlemen's
agreement these guys have worked out hey
I'm gonna probably lash you in a press
conference about Trey but I'm not
actually gonna carry that out formally
yeah and know
reports yet as to whether Shinzo Abe A's
wife is still pretending not to
understand English around Trampas she
seemed to talk to Milania but maybe both
of them have some communications
problems so Japan was the first stop
then Trump went to South Korea where
there was a discussion about or actually
the the signing off of arms purchases
and then this is a case where I guess
Trump is kind of making deals or
something like that but when I actually
read about them it's not clear Trump is
really responsible for the deal-making
that's always the case with arms deals
of course Trump is kicking it into high
gear he is doing his salesmen pitch here
on behalf of the u.s. weapons
manufacturers but yeah I mean arms deals
are often like this they take years if
not decades to complete and they can be
announced multiple times over in fact
going through the details about both the
Japanese and the South Koreans arms
purchases and many of these had already
been announced or had been announced
during President Obama's tenure and as
is again often the case with these arms
deals they can be scrapped years ahead
they can be revised or shifted one of
the other interesting observations I'll
say about this though is it's good for
America to get the jobs and the revenue
of these sales that's what Trump keeps
talking about but in in both of these
countries there are concerns and in
particularly here in South Korea there
have been scandals in the past about
South Korean government's paying for
weapons they didn't need oftentimes ones
that are of lesser quality I don't think
that's a concern here with the u.s. arms
purchase but domestic political concerns
are budding into America's sort of and
Trump's sort of trade promotion here on
behalf of the Americans weapons industry
and there is some concern that you know
President moon here in South Korea might
be buying things to try and placate
Trump that South Korea ultimately
doesn't need so it's a kind of a two-way
street and I'll also say it's a little
bit awkward at a time when Trump is
talking about the preeminent threat
caused by North Korea requiring
international unity that he's also kind
of engaging in sort of petty complaints
about a trade imbalance it makes one
think maybe we should have stick with
the first issue if that is so deadly
serious
but he is putting both in the same
sentence and not apologizing for it and
while in South Korea well I don't know
it was it was today where you are
although it's already tomorrow it was
yesterday here even though it was today
there yesterday here I don't know if
that's clear Trump gave a good the point
is front gave a speech in South Korea
about North Korean policy and there was
a lot of discussion as to sort of the
change in tone but at the same time
speaking directly to the North Korean
leader leader Kim jong-un from only you
know a couple hundred miles away what
was the running of his speech there oh
that Daddy okay even closer than I
thought yeah what was the reception
there uh well the reception was mixed I
mean on one hand I think there's relief
that President Trump didn't blow into
South Korea with the rhetorical head of
steam that characterized his UN General
Assembly speech where he coined Rocket
Man and and really you know threatened
of fire and fury against North Korea a
complete destruction I guess was maybe
the term from the UN speech he didn't do
that and I think credit to John Kelly
who personally managed this entire
itinerary he's kept Trump away from
press conferences largely where there's
gonna be a lot of back-and-forth with
reporters and he stayed on script almost
everywhere and in his speech to the
South Korean National Assembly he
largely was restrained I mean there were
some comments saying look we've got
nukes we've got all these you know we've
got submarines we've got all these
aircraft carriers you know we'll do
whatever we need to do to defend
ourselves but I mean I think that the
part of his remarks that is getting more
play especially from the White House and
I think is a little perhaps dubious is
that the White House is saying Trump
sort of offered out the prospect of
diplomacy to North Korea he said if
we'll forget everything he did in the
past I mean it was horrible but we're
willing to talk to you on condition that
you stop your nuclear development
program and end your missile program and
you know this this complete irreversible
verifiable denuclearization has been the
big goal of American foreign policy
towards North Korea for decades which
has failed I mean it is it is two
holding out this ultimate hope for the
ultimate prize North Korea as a
precondition for even talking and I
don't think there's any prospect
North Korea giving up its nuclear
program so I think you know South
Korea's a society this is in particular
the the president moon jae-in here
believes in diplomacy deeply and yet
president Trump's attempt at setting up
a diplomatic offer seemed quite
disingenuous just because of how
impossible and impossibly likely it
would be that the negotiating partner
would ever sort of buy into the talks in
the first place and I think that is seen
as as a misstep and a missed opportunity
to engage in meaningful diplomacy and
spread the load I mean it is possible
you can have a military element but also
be engaging in diplomacy Trump showed a
willingness to sort of engage in the
former without the latter so in terms of
the reaction there in South Korea I mean
whether it's among the population or the
foreign policy establishment whoever
what what would they like to do what
approach are they thinking of here yeah
I think what I've heard a recommendation
about how the US should think about
North Korea that we really don't use is
we should think about this like Soviet
containment not a threat that can be
dealt with quickly
of course not through like a quick
military strike but a multi-decade long
containment struggle and when you start
to conceive of North Korea in that light
and maybe accept that they're going to
be a nuclear power then you would start
to figure out a whole suite of options
one of them is outreach to the people
use humanitarian aid try and convince
North Koreans that the world cares about
them so they'll be more brave in the
event of a challenge to the Kim regime
and then you know cutting off diplomatic
ties sapping the prestige of Kim jong-un
and his senior leadership and the final
one that relates directly to the Soviet
Union is maybe we should deploy American
tactical nuclear weapons to South Korea
sort of a step back from the nuclear
proliferation debate but maybe it could
allow us to go two steps forward much
like we put nuclear weapons in Western
Europe and then start a bargaining with
the Soviets about a commensurate
drawdown that strategy is being talked
about in South Korea as a possible way
of thinking about North Korea so that
long-term multi decades Soviet style
containment is if framing that some
South Korean diplomats are using I think
maybe is the way we should start
thinking about North Korea in the United
States well it's already been quite a
trip Trump now in China eventually to
Vietnam Philippine
and of course the real question that
that people have is how was the sushi in
Japan a better counter with how are the
burgers right yeah that that would be
the question for Donald Trump that would
be that that's what I was a fan was
great even off a conveyer belt for a
dollar a piece in the Giri it was quite
something I bet I bet all right Luke
Vargas he is of course United Nations
bureau chief for talk media news joining
us from South Korea where it is very
very late now so Luke we will let you go
thanks so much for talking to us today
thanks David bye-bye okay good it will